hey everyone it's Justine and today I
partnered with Best Buy to show you some
unexpected Tech finds
even though I'm one of the biggest Best
Buy fans it is always so surprising to
find things on their website that I
never thought Best Buy would carry all
of the things that I'm showing you today
were things that I've had on my purchase
list so I was so surprised and excited
to find them at Best Buy
[Music]
first up let's talk about health and
wellness now I was so excited to find
this TRX trainer at Best Buy because
this is something that I've always loved
at gyms so I was beyond hyped to see
they carry not only the TRX Elite system
suspension but all of the accessories
like this TRX X Mount plate and this
invisi Mount plate the install is super
simple you just have to install these
plates either on the wall or the ceiling
and you're good to go and now I'm here
about to install it in my own garage at
home can't wait to try this out
foreign
here it is
so we have this little mesh bag which is
great because you can actually take this
with you anywhere I even saw online
people have like tied these to like
trees to the doors of hotel rooms so you
can basically have a portable gym
wherever you have this
looks like it's the door anchor oh a
little bracelet here's our suspension
anchor
and it has some resistance bands I love
resistance workouts and I'm a huge fan
of resistance bands even if you can't
take the TRX system with you these
things are incredible we've got a little
workout exercise
poster oh we're definitely hanging this
up
I watched a bunch of review videos and
I've seen a lot of people make this
mistake never clip
these anchors onto each other you never
want the metal to be touching the metal
[Music]
this is the moment that I've been
waiting for I've been preparing for this
honestly for days I've watched so many
YouTube videos I was gonna hire a
professional but honestly it's literally
two holes that I have to drill and screw
in I'm gonna Mark our holes now it's
time to drill
[Music]
all right so that looks pretty solid now
that everything's unboxed our Mount is
officially mounted
let's hang it up
okay our poster is all set up our TRX is
hung and now it's time to test it out
[Music]
nothing yet stay tuned another product
that I love is the bosu sports balance
trainer this is also a very simple gym
accessory that I've never owned but
always loved using at the gym much like
the TRX this is another great tool for
doing body weight exercises Advanced AB
training and mostly used for improving
your balance I clearly have not been
working on my balance recently so I am
so glad that I now have this added to my
gym it's all set up this is so exciting
oh yeah I I mean I feel
so Fit already there's also a bunch of
workouts that you can do so I've got
this little QR code that I can scan and
this will give you some manuals workouts
and wall charts and I can add those to
my TRX wall charts over there
[Music]
now that we have our fitness out of the
way let's talk about travel so recently
I went to Europe and as a tech reviewer
I forgot one of the most important
things that anybody really traveling out
of the country would need and that is a
travel converter or an adapter this is
the Insignia converter and adapter so
it'll convert from 240 to 120 so you'll
be able to use this in different
countries it's super easy to use too you
just go like that
for wherever it is that you're traveling
to so over here on the side you have the
adapter and converter so you can switch
to whichever mode you'd like and there's
also two lights on the front that'll let
you know which mode you're in there's
even two USB a ports on the bottom I
also was traveling with an electric
toothbrush that was really large so when
I saw this quip plastic smart electric
toothbrush I couldn't wait to try it out
it's small compact and will actually
earn you a warts like free brush heads
products and gift cards as you track
your brushing habits with their free app
there is nothing that I love more than
earning awards for doing everyday tasks
so I also like that this has a little
toothbrush cover so I can put my
toothbrush in there and it has this
adhesive on the back so I can just
basically stick that to wherever I want
and my toothbrush is ready to go
for my next brush no travel is complete
without a Mophie power station this is
the XXL 20 000 milliamp hour portable
charger I really like this one because
it has two usba and one USBC giving you
the flexibility to charge multiple
things with various outputs it's also a
pretty small size considering how much
power it will be able to deliver
this summer I've been riding my bike a
lot more and I haven't had a good bike
lot so I picked up this Kryptonite
Evolution 1090 integrated chain this
thing is super tough and it makes me
feel so much better leaving my bike
Somewhere Out of Sight when I go to a
coffee shop or the beach it's a hundred
millimeter size chain links made from
steel it has three stainless steel keys
and one actually has an LED light with
replaceable batteries time to go for a
bike ride I'm so excited about this bike
lock because with an electric bike you
need to really have something that's
pretty substantial so hopefully this is
rated 8 out of 10 as far as security
rating so let's take you
out for a spin
[Applause]
[Music]
so you may have seen this in my previous
videos I've talked about the Thera gun I
use it after workouts I've been using it
for the past couple of years and I
absolutely love it but this is the
theraface pro so if you've never heard
of theragun it's basically just like a
massage gun that's able to get into like
trigger points and get into deep tissue
well now they have a face version it
comes with a bunch of different
accessories I haven't unboxed it yet so
let's see what's inside
[Music]
it comes in a nice little traveling case
too
so inside
we have the Thera body which looks very
similar in kind of the style and shape
to some of their other devices this is
bringing that same concept of relaxing
the muscles but for your face it'll give
you a firming or microcurrent facial
massage LED red and blue light therapy
deep cleaning it has an OLED screen and
120 Minutes of battery life so we can
change the different color LED lights I
mean I feel youthful already just one
simple pass
here we go
[Music]
definitely feel
I feel relaxed
interesting that's cool so you can
change the intensity I'm excited to try
this out more but here's all of the
accessories that we have you can just
swap these pretty easily
just like so you guys aren't even gonna
recognize me anymore after my therapace
Pro treatments
[Music]
I recently got a new studio and have
been wanting to upgrade the thermostat
to the Google Nest learning Smart Wi-Fi
thermostat I had them in my home for a
while and have always loved the
integration with Google and the way that
the nest is able to learn my habits to
conserve energy also because it's
connected to an app it's super easy to
control from anywhere even if I'm not at
the studio at the time
[Music]
lastly we have this hover one Jive
electric folding scooter it'll get the
16 mile Max operating range and up to 14
miles per hour max speed this summer I
found myself going to the pool and
meeting friends around town a lot of
times trying to find parking around the
beach or pool is impossible so even if I
had to drive somewhere I could just fold
this up put it in my car park far away
and if I need to I can cruise to my
destination
okay first of all let's check out a few
of my favorite highlights it's got a
bell
gotta love it this does have three
different modes and it also has a light
now not only does it have a light up
here up front but check this out we've
got some LEDs here on the board as well
we've got a kickstand which is clearly
always something that's important got
some brake lights back there
so this is our throttle so basically to
get started you get going hit the
throttle it also has this nice Speed
Lock function too so if you are going on
longer rides you don't have to
continually hold the throttle this is
your brake this also has a really nice
folding mechanism so we just pull up
right here pull out
fold
and you're ready to take this wherever
you need to go I never thought that I
was a scooter person but here we are
apparently I am one
if you guys are
in any of the things that I showed you
today I will put a link in the
description to bestbuy.com I had so much
fun checking out all of this unexpected
Tech leave me a comment below and let me
know what your most unexpected Tech find
is that you've found at Best Buy I'll
see you guys in the next video don't
forget to subscribe hit the Bell to be
notified when I post new videos and I'll
see you in the next one already said
that but you know what I mean bye
foreign
[Music]